How to Train Your Dragon 3 has been out
for a while now and fans seem to have
given their ultimate stamp of approval
with box office numbers soaring who
knows maybe we'll finally track down
another Night Fury we definitely got our
romantic feel this time around with
Astrid and hiccup finally getting
married and toothless actually finding
himself a gorgeous light fury girlfriend
we also got a pretty cool villain who
kept us on the edge of our seats the
entire time hey everyone it's heroes
Noir and welcome back to the things I'd
like to start off this video with a
shout out to our awesome things remember
be lean we totally agree with your
comment on why astronaut make the best
animated couple if you want a shout out
in our next video I'm gonna need you to
hit that subscribe button give this
video a big thumbs up and of course
watch till the very end
now let's get started so when it comes
to video animations like DreamWorks How
to Train Your Dragon
we can't help but praise all these sweet
scenes he's your age
brave scenes it takes more than a little
fog up the jovian and even the
tear-jerking ones no but I figured this
time around maybe I can bring you guys
something different more of a villain
appreciation post perhaps now don't get
me wrong I love rooting for the good
guys but there can't really be a good
story without a good villain now can
there so the villain from How to Train
Your Dragon 3 is for a movie grizzly
Grimm oh the grizzly famous back where
I'm from grandma is a feared and
powerful dragon hunter and right off the
bat the movie makes sure to let us know
that nothing is accidental when it comes
to old Gribble now let's start off with
this villains motive at least from what
we've seen so far grimille seems to only
hunt for the glory of it he's built up
quite the reputation eliminating night
Furies so killing toothless would only
add to another glory notch on this guy's
belt for starters he pretty much has to
be great the creators of the film it
pretty clear that we won't be getting
another How to Train Your Dragon movie
for a very long time to come so they had
to end this one with a bang
it's a hidden dragon wife Wow not only
does this final antagonist need to be
smart unbelievable but he also has to
leave a lasting impression throughout
the movie he is always one step ahead of
hiccup in the game we see this when he
uses his logic alone to catch hiccup and
the Vikings in no time when they are in
hiding he is also able to control
dragons using all sorts of potions that
he creates himself he totally uses this
to his advantage in the final fight of
the movie this villain is totally worth
his spot in the final How to Train Your
Dragon movie but here is what makes him
epic 500 every night furious except
yours so the only way I can really
explain grandma's obsession with night
Furies is that a Night Fury was this
villains first kill if I throw it way
back to the first movie of the trilogy
we know that Vikings take dragon killing
classes at the age of just 15 this
prepares them for their final exam Genki
cups exam he had enormous pressure from
his father to kill his dragon but he
never ended up going through with it
well what would have happened if he did
go through with it what would have
happened if hiccup actually killed a
dragon I hope you guys see where I'm
going with this because this is where
grimille comes into play
canopy in at the creators of the story
found the perfect match for hiccup in
his final movie but actually coming up
with a villain who is the counterpart of
hiccup this wouldn't be the first time
that the writers mirror his character
initially we see that toothless is
unable to fly after hurting his tail fin
hiccup then builds him a replacement
hiccup later also loses his like during
the first movies final battle with both
of these characters missing something I
guess they found that together they
could make up for that loss this fits in
perfectly with the final movie
especially if you paid attention to this
specific sentence nothing
How to Train Your Dragon 3 involved a
lot of growing for both toothless and
hiccup they needed to learn that these
two had their own strengths and were
just exactly who they were
even when the other wasn't around but
just like toothless was the half of
hiccup that he thought he needed
what if grimille was the counterpart of
hiccup that would have come to life had
he killed the first dragon in his final
test and the final fight scene you see
that these two are evenly matched except
for one minor detail
hiccup had already lost his leg just for
the sake of his love for dragons in the
end it was hiccups prosthetic leg that
ended up saving him and he never would
have gotten it without his love for
dragons and his urge to protect them
this is something that grimille would
never do so if grandma being the evil
half of hiccup doesn't make him a great
villain then I don't know what does so
be sure to let me know in the comments
below what you guys think does a great
villain make a great hero and a great
movie
it's your o snort this has been fun and
I'll catch you guys next time
on the things
[Music]